hello everyone and welcome to the
semi-finals of the fiji world cup we are
in the tie breaks uh and it's young
shirt of duda versus magnus carlsen
they're two classical games ended in a
draw sadly
i didn't show any uh of the games
because the first one was really a
snooze fest and the second one was uh
sort of an exciting snoozefest so i
decided that you guys would not
appreciate any of those games but
this one packs a lot more action so
we're gonna uh
show this one uh it's the first of their
rapid match
and duda has the white pieces so without
further ado let's check it out and see
what
this game is about uh do that with the
white pieces
opens with e4 uh we have e5 knight to f3
knight to c6 and bishop to b5 and
since uh sergey karjakin is already in
the finals
uh the winner of this match will of
course face uh karjakin uh for the
uh will uh or or uh do they even play
each other i don't know because they had
this like
uh whoever reaches the the final that's
it they win but uh
maybe this year they will have like the
finals i could be mistaking but i have
to check i
actually have no idea uh so here we have
bishop to b5
knight to f6 and now d3 so the berlin
defense is on the board we have d6 and
now uh
c3 grabbing more space in the center and
preparing a for b4
uh we have a6 by black bishop to a4 and
now
bishop b5 chasing the bishop away is the
way
this is usually played but magnus goes
for his uh
signature move and that is of course g6
it's very rare that magnus will play an
opening without playing the g6 move
uh we have castles and now bishop to g7
rook to e1 now and magnus castles we
have h3
and now uh there are some moves that are
known in this position b5 again being
the most popular one but magnus goes for
uh knight back to b8 and now uh it's
very usual in the royal opus with black
that you will move this knight sometimes
to a5 sometimes the b8
sometimes maybe even the e7 to be able
to grab more space in the center with b5
and c5 so here
we have knight beat to d2 yeah and sorry
and of course it is as of move 9 that we
have a completely new game
so knight b to d2 uh and now knight b
to d7 reshuffling the knight with bishop
back to c2 as you know b5 is coming
and magnus of course uh uh executed
uh so b5 with a4 now challenging that b5
pawn
and bishop to b7 and now of course b4
very popular nowadays to just push
on that queen side we have c5 magnus
of course fighting for the center like
this now with very nice controller d4
also challenging the b4 pawn
and the duda captures on c5 we have pawn
captures and now
knight captures and now duda has to
decide what to do here
d4 seems very interesting but he decides
to capture here we have eight characters
on b
five eight captures and now bishop to a3
so challenging carlson's knight here on
c5
and there's the immediate threat of just
captures characters and winning the e5
pawn so magnus just defends it
uh you could play queen to b6 that's
also possible just connecting rooks and
you will be defending your knight with
the queen but magnus decides for rook to
e8
uh and now comes queen to b1 by duda
uh also very interesting is c4 because
it's a direct threat to that b5 pawn and
the point is if you capture on c4 which
seems good for black because you're
capturing you know towards the center
uh then we go into this forcing bishop
captures on c5 let's say rook captures
on a1 queen captures and now after we
play d
captures on c five knight captures now
with the triple attack on the e5 pawn
so uh maybe also uh something that that
was possible but okay after rook t8 we
have queen to b1 by duda now attacking
the b5 pawn
uh and now comes bishop to c6 magnus
defends it and prepares a very nice idea
uh the situation on the clock as these
are rapid games uh is
uh duda some 13 minutes on the clock
magnus around 10 minutes on the clock
so here we have d4 finally uh e captures
on b
for c captures and now comes the move
that magnus prepared with bishop to c6
and that is of course
b4 always always a good move uh
now there's the question of what do you
do do you capture the knight to do
capture the pawn with the bishop do you
capture the pawn with the queen
uh a lot of very good options but just
to explore some of them now if you go
after the knight d
captures on c5 we're gonna capture the
bishop and now black is left with a very
strong pass pawn here
you're gonna capture on d6 but now
there's even knight d7 opening up for
this
beautiful diagonal for the dark square
bishop rook a2 we're gonna play knight
to the e5
and you will have to deal with this pawn
for the rest of the game okay you do
have this pawn on d6 but it's
very likely that black will be able to
capture it so it is possible
duda doesn't like this idea another
thing after bishop
after b4 you could just grab the pawn
but that kind of runs into knight c
captures on e4 yeah and now we're going
to play knight captures an e4 knight
capture sun beef
on e4 bishop captures bishop captures
rook captures rook captures and
now rook captures an a8 and the problem
is after queen captures an a8
the rook is defended here so this
capture fest definitely favors black so
not something duda is interested in so
after this b4
it seems duda was prepared for it
because he played bishop to b2 right
away so
avoiding all of these lines and now
magnus has to deal with this knight
being under attack but he just plays
b3 now again sing okay you can capture
on c5 i'm gonna capture on b3
and that's exactly what it does well you
could play bishop d3
it really makes sense to get rid of this
pawn
so d captures on c5 we have bishop b
captures on c2
queen captures and now d captures on c5
and now the problem is uh going after
the c5 pawn like this
runs into bishop captures on e4 and it's
possible but it's maybe giving black a
bit much
knight captures knight captures and now
let's say we trade off the rooks rook
captures queen captures
um it's uh i mean it's completely equal
position not much to
to look at and and then definitely not
something to look forward to with white
because you know
if you draw this you're playing against
magnus and he will have the
white pieces next round so instead after
the captures on c5
knight to e5 now threatening to capture
the bishop on c6
and now bishop to a4 magnus attacks the
queen here
and both players are now around seven
minutes on the clock
and magnus here is trying to get some
activity here for example if you do that
play something like queen to c4 here
then
i guess his idea was a rook captures an
e5
and it's a very tricky move because if
bishop captures we're going to capture
on d2
and now you can't capture the bishop
because the rook hangs here so we're
going to move the rook
and now we're still threatening the
bishop and now we're going to play
queen back to d7 defend the bishop like
this now we're going to play rook to b6
attack the knight here so a very
tactical line and now
knights the e8 offering a trait of
bishop so after bishop captures knight
captures for example queen captures on
c5
we would have this position where duda
would be up upon and he would have a
a a rook for a knight in the bishop but
magnus of course would be very happy to
play this
uh as he didn't like playing two rooks
against uh you know
uh being down the exchange that the duda
was
in the previous classical game uh but
okay here after bishop to a4 we have the
immediate rook captures on a4
we have rook captures on a4 and now
queen captures on a4
magnus grabs the knight on d2 and now
queen back to a1
now again putting pressure along this
diagonal so magnus goes knight h5 he
says all right if this knight moves
we're just gonna trade here
and the thing is uh you could play uh
something like knight to c for attack
the queen and attack the bishop here but
the magnus just trades here bishop
captures knight captures and then you
have to deal with this
past pawn not not a lot of fun so
instead we have bishop to c3 by duda
preparing a very very tricky line
because uh the only thing defending the
f7 pawn
is the king that's what duda is hoping
for we have queen to c2 by magnus and
now
queen to a7 attacking the df7 pawn here
so if magnus captures on c3 we're just
going to capture on f7 and then pick up
the rook here with
chick so magnus instantly played queen
to b3 now
defending this and now uh what do you do
the knight here is hanging you have to
do something about this
and there is only one move that helps do
that uh control the
the the position and that is queen
captures on c5 so he wins this pawn
and now nicely defends the knight but
now magnus says knight to f4 and now
there are
uh so many forks here that you have to
calculate
the the simplest idea would be just
removing the defender of the d3 square
because knight d3 then
attacks the queen and the rook so this
is the threat bishop captures bishop
captures knight d3
and you have to defend against this the
only move that properly defends is
rook to e3 and this is what duda plays
and
he's very much down on the clock he's
two minutes on the clock magnus some
four minutes on the clock
and now magnus played queen to d1 check
uh hoping for king to h2 because if king
to h2 queen f1 just wins for him you're
threatening checkmate
and now if the rook moves you're just
going to play 92. now the king
does not have an escape square the
knight covers that and queen to g1 is
the threat of checkmate so very very
uh bad position okay you can play f4 the
queen will guard g1 but then we're just
gonna you know
capture on f4 we could also pick up the
exchange like
anything is possible here but black
would be completely winning
so instead after this queen to d1 check
duda quickly went back
rook to e1 and now magnus went queen to
b3 we
wrote the e3 and here both players were
down to 30 seconds because magnus spent
most of his time calculating what
what can happen if we play bishop
captures on e5
since this is the only uh well possible
continuation that
doesn't involve black uh you know having
a worse position
but in the end we had queen to d1 check
rook to e1 queen to b3 and he was in
this position that
uh well players agreed to a draw as
there is nothing more to be done here
and truth be told there is nothing more
to be done here because if magnus
continued with this idea for example
rook to e3 and then bishop captures an
e5
which kind of is the strongest
continuation we run into bishop captures
queen d1 check
attacking the king here king to h2 and
now knight to e2
threatening checkmate but now white has
rook captures on e2 and magnus
not interested in playing this because
if queen captures you have queen to d4
and now
uh yes uh black is up the exchange but
white has so much pressure along the
dark squares it's gonna be
very very hard for black to even
play this for example queen h5 we want
to bring our queen here to help out
defending the dark squares bishop f6 if
queen h6 we're going to play e5
and now this bishop here is a monster
you can never
do anything here with black if this rook
ever moves the back rank it's
just checkmate so black will not be able
to achieve anything here
uh so of course magnus knows this and
after queen to b3 he said all right
let's
let's get a draw here we're going to try
with white in the next one
and duda will try his best with the
black pieces because this is the second
rapid game and whoever wins that one is
the winner of the entire match if not we
go into shorter rap
games than the blitz than the armageddon
so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it another draw between these
two fine gentlemen
uh we're going to see what happens in
the next one so uh stay tuned for that
i would like to thank jeffrey johnson uh
pradeep prakar uh boris raden check uh
parmenion
and david kimura for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the
semi-final match checking up on your
wonderful suggestions
and whatever else happens in the chess
world thank you all i will see you soon
and have an excellent rest of your day